[Musique]
j'ai voulu insister surtout sur
faire connaître aux enfants les
matériaux avant qu'ils sachent comment
s'en débarrasser comment les recycler
parce qu'on s'est rendu compte très vite
qu'il y avait une grande méconnaissance
même des matériaux les plus simples
[Musique]
on fait des petits ateliers tout simple
et puis on regarde en gros ce qu'on a
sur soi puis se rendre compte aussi
parce qu'on a il y a aussi des
fermetures éclairées en métal il y a des
boutons en plastique ou en bois ou en
liège et puis nos tissus ont été éteints
et puis on a rajouté un petit peu
d'élastique pour avoir un jean beaucoup
plus confortable donc en fait c'est
toute une évolution pour faire
comprendre aux enfants que tout n'est
pas acheté par exemple dans le plastique
et aussi que ça ne va pas se recycler la
même manière selon qu'on est un pull en
laine
naturelle ou des fibres synthétiques
[Musique]
le tissu ça peut être pour refaire des
chiffons pour faire des isolants des
isolants à la maison mais aussi au
niveau industriel et puis ne pas oublier
bien sûr que les les vêtements peuvent
servir à d'autres et ça peut donc être
vendu ou encore mieux donner
[Musique]
qu'il faut aussi qu'ils comprennent
pourquoi leurs parents ou leurs
grands-parents en fait ont tellement
apprécié d'avoir ces nouveaux matériaux
parce qu'il faut pas non plus qu'on
devienne dans une aire ou en fait on est
en train de tout critiquer
en disant mais ils ont fait que du mal
[Musique]